you familiar with this guy yes i am
big time running back one of the
greatest runs of all time was him
against the new orleans saints he was
trucking people
left and right and then uh they he
trucked his way into the super bowl
and uh
they won a super bowl um i don't know
has it been i don't know maybe eight
years ago at this point i don't know
hello but the guy's a beast yeah quote
unquote character and a half character
and a half beast mode activating beast
mode
so marshawn lynch he's one of these guys
that likes to save his money good
respect so there's some rookies in the
nfl where he basically says look
let me teach you let me teach you the
ways of beast mode so one guy that he
teaches is a rookie running back for the
pittsburgh steelers called najee harris
so anyway some of these stuffs is proves
that he's still the goat of quotes see
if we can get marshawn lynch on the uh
saskatchewan i like that make note
so it's no secret the five-time pro
bowler wasn't all that talkative during
his playing days in the nfl this is an
outsider story he was known for his flat
out ignoring the media
um and refusing to answer those
questions but when it comes to giving
genuine advice to rookie's financial
advice specifically coming to league
marshawn lynch doesn't have a problem
doing that
check this out
he basically pulls najee harris aside
running back for the pittsburgh steelers
and he says uh
here's some advice on how to handle
yourself off the field buddy
how to handle the business off the field
we know you need to do on the field
run off run score touchdowns do your
thing
but here's the deal off the field
and then uh najee says
you know what he always tells me tell me
if you've heard this before if you can't
buy it twice then don't buy it at all
hey he's been watching the sauce guys oh
yeah if you can't buy it twice don't buy
it at all he always tells me how
important is to save your money and
don't lose focus on the most important
thing and that's what you do on the
field because that's what brings you a
lot of the marketing deals so never lose
focus of where the real money is
is where it's coming from and what you
do on the field so i'm just happy like i
think
a crazy amount of nfl players go broke
uh five years into retirement
you did 60 percent of nfl players go
broke you did a video on yesterday i've
done a video of this it's some stupid
number like whatever number you think it
is it's more they just go broke after
retirement
if there's one sport i wouldn't want to
play it's nfl
okay
they don't have guaranteed contracts
yeah they don't have guarantee mlb
baseball nba hockey
love to play these sports
soccer your favorite thing you're you're
a chelsea guy i'm a huge chelsea these
guys get paid galore and their contracts
they they're getting that money nfl yeah
oh thanks for your services oh you
busted your knee have a nice life yeah
thanks yeah thanks
oh your hip hip surgery good luck out
there so that's why these guys want to
get guaranteed money up front in their
contract because at any point these nfl
contracts could run out anyway marshawn
lynch knows the game
knows i don't even know if he's playing
right now i don't know if he's in the
league currently a lot of time like i
think a season ago he was not even
playing and they called him in last
minute but you know what team marshawn
lynch can play on any day of the week
what's that the save that money team hey
he can play ball
save that money so if you can't buy it
twice then don't buy it at all
can't buy it twice
oh we got a sound effects thank you
simple rule like that for someone like
najee um
najee harris
that could be the difference between
going into debt being broke
or actually success off the field yeah
um
that's advice from marshawn
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken